quand tu es une gonzesse la rue c'est la
double peine c'est la double peine
tu te fais violer beaucoup plus souvent
que quand tu es un mec tu te fais
attaquer racketter il faut protéger de
tout
[Musique]
oui j'ai eu des épisodes comme ça chaque
histoire est vraiment spécifique et
parfois peintes à la honte qui
s'accompagne de ça c'est à dire que tu
ne dis pas qu'ils ont en tout cas moi
c'était mon coach allez pas me vanter
que que j'avais dormi entre entre deux
de trucs de vitrine avec un carton ou
derrière une poubelle parce que là
j'étais sûr que si les mecs passer une
voyais pas où et c'est ça tu le dis pas
parce que tu tu culpabilises d'être
pauvreté une gonzesse la rue c'est toute
cette double peine
tu te fais violer beaucoup plus souvent
que quand tu es un mec tu te fais
attaquer racketter qu'il faut protéger
de tout et toujours sur le qui vive à 3
360 degrés
quant à depuis rien et que tu peux plus
avoir accès à rien bah voilà en défaut
tu vas tu à tailler une pipe pour
pouvoir dormir chez le mec qui tue
taille la pipe ou tu vas vendre ton cul
pour avoir de quoi bouffer ou voilà tu
as tout ça ça existe aussi chez les mecs
mais c'est beaucoup plus plus terrible
quand tu es une personne de sexe féminin
tout est dix fois plus problématique
quand tu es une gonzesse qu'au 10 fois
plus un truc tout con
quant à tes règles et t'as pas de quoi
acheter des trucs alors tu vas chouravé
tu vas toujours avec des serviettes et
machin tout mais il faut aller voilà
peut-être qu'apple tente a pas pu ou n'a
pas pu ou machin tout ça comment tu fais
et tu te mets des journaux et les
machins on n'en parle jamais de ça
pourquoi ces trucs là c'est pas
remboursés par la sécu par exemple et
tout est comme ça tout est comme ça pour
te laver pour aller pisser les mecs
alors il ya des pistes debout tu fais ça
tu prends un truc comme un cornet de
frites et tu puisses de vous mettez en a
partout après ça pue alors tu es plus tu
vas y aie aie
et puis la violence le fait de voilà
quand tu te retrouves avec trois quatre
mecs qu'il soit dessus bombe à un moment
donné c'est c'est la vie ou ou levitt et
ben tu prends le 8
voilà et tu gardes la vie
[Musique]
mais accident de parcours mais il ya
plein de choses qui font que qu'à un
moment donné tu sais pu goûter que tu
sais plus qui tu es tu sais plus si tu
as le droit d'exister tu qui font que tu
te trouves tu as l'impression d'être une
sous merde que quoi que tu fasses quoi
que tu dises quoi que tu penses tu n'as
pas le droit d'exister tarifs des choses
comme ça qui t'amène les unes derrière
les autres à vivre des trucs vraiment
pas rigolo quoi des agressions te mettra
près dans des systèmes qui font que ben
voilà auto tu deviens d'agresser tu ne
deviens agresseurs et etc etc
mais j'ai rencontré des gens qui petit à
petit ne montraient qu'il y avait qu une
autre issue était possible que j'étais
que ma parole c'est pour qu'elle valait
plus qu'un autre mais qu'elle avait le
droit que j'avais le droit d'exister et
moi moi j'ai vécu ça sur un plateau de
sur un plateau de théâtre
ça s'est passé en 20 minutes quelqu'un
qui m'a invité à y monter pour faire un
exercice à la con et je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais lourdes est debout
devant des gens qui me regardait et il
me regardait et il me demandait de
parler et ce que je disais même s'ils
étaient des trucs qui me semblent
insignifiants
j'avais le droit de vivre j'avais droit
de parler d'exister et là ça a été
retournement de situation et là j'ai pas
l'acheter c'était la petite porte qui
s'ouvrait la gelée pas lâcher je suis
entré dedans comme j'ai pu
[Musique]